What do you think when you take
a look at these two images?
Do you see any connection?
Maybe, maybe not.
We will talk about it later.
Now look at this picture.
My dad keeps watching a lot
of movies of this man,
and he has his own version of a very
famous dialogue from one of his movies:
"There are two kinds of people
in the world.
The ones who create problems
and the ones who solve them."
I want to be in the latter category.
Now, let me tell you what
I really want to do,
besides showing simple
correlational pictures.
I want to solve a problem,
a very big problem.
A 5-trillion-piece problem
that's plaguing us today:
the problem of what we throw
into our oceans.
Did you know by 2050
we will have the same, or maybe more,
plastic in the ocean than fish?
Or if we were to take all the plastic
on the ocean surface and pile it up -
do you know how far
a distance it would cover?
Take a guess.
It would be enough to stack two-liter
bottles from here to the moon and back
twice.
That's one long walk.
To put into perspective
the ocean pollution, as you can imagine,
is a very, very big problem.
While these statistics are huge
and mind-boggling,
what really moved me was the impact
that this waste has on life.
I learned something about whales recently.
Only July 2013, this young whale ended
up on the shores of Northern Netherlands.
The people were very surprised to find
an unusually bloated stomach.
When they opened it up, they found,
among other things,
two horse pipes,
nine-meter rope,
and 37 pounds of plastic.
It's cause of death?
Intestinal blockage.
What emotions run within you
when you see this helpless seal
entangled within this net?
Anger, pain, or perhaps even shame?
There are many more
horrifying pictures i have seen,
which I found extremely disturbing.
Every time I see people eating fish,
I feel that we're not just feeding
plastic to fish,
we are feeding it to ourselves as well.
The plastic we dispose,
which ends up in the ocean,
gets consumed by small organisms
which are later eaten by bigger fish,
which might just be the fish
that ends up on our plate.
Talk about the vicious karmic cycle.
All this while we are trying to find
water and life on other planets,
and I think and smile.
If we cannot do justice to life
and water on our planet,
what are we trying to achieve
by searching it outside our Earth?
With so much happening around us,
it got a bit depressing
and overwhelming for me
that I felt I had to do
something about it.
Hence, I came up with an idea
of an invention
that could help make the oceans
a cleaner place:
an ocean cleaner called ERVIS.
Now getting back to the two pictures
we saw in the beginning.
Garbage plus the sink
equals to ERVIS.
So what is ERVIS all about?
ERVIS is an intelligent ship which
sucks waste from the surface of the ocean
and cleans it.
It all started last year when I saw
some documentaries
on water pollution
and how it is plaguing us.
I also happened to see Boyan Slat's
TED Talk on the same problem
and how he wanted to tackle it.
Then one day, as I came home
from playing football,
my mom asked me to wash my hands.
And as I went to the sink
to get the dirt off,
I saw how the water flowed
into the sink hole
and an idea came to my mind
and I smiled.
As I saw the swirl of the water
whirlpooling down the drain,
I figured I could use the same concept
to suck in waste from
the surface of the water
and store it in a chamber.
So I rushed to the bathtub,
filled it with water and my toys,
opened the nozzle,
and was delighted to see
a whirlpool being created
which started to suck in the water
and toys in the tub
and I immediately knew what I had to do.
And so I went to my room,
drew a rough model,
a circular ship with saucers attached,
a very futuristic design,
much like the USS Enterprise
from Star Trek -
we all loved the series, right?
So I zoomed around the house,
scrambled and collected the following:
an inflatable tube,
straws, connection pipes,
scissors,
some cardboard to make the saucers,
and voila!
ERVIS Version 1 was born.
This was just the first draft.
The propellers weren't automated
and it only lasted seven seconds
in water before coming apart,
but there it was,
my ERVIS,
my vision of changing the oceans.
I then got a little more serious,
did some exhaustive research,
and realized that a circular shape
was not very efficient,
so I redesigned it
to be more stretched with curves.
I worked with a 3D designer
to make the new design and model of ERVIS.
Another interesting fact I came across
during my research
was that large ships like the one you see
in the picture
are actually one of the
biggest pollutants on Earth.
They use high-sulfur fuel,
which creates a lot of air pollution.
I wanted to make sure ERVIS didn't
become part of that problem,
so I looked at renewable energy,
like solar and wind,
and cleaner ones like hydrogen
and RNG.
I investigated into using
lighter materials, like graphene,
which is as durable as steel,
and making it autonomous, like Tesla.
I eventually want to see multiple
ERVISes manning the ocean,
cleaning and scavenging the waste.
So, what do I want ERVIS to do?
As I was doing my research, going through
a variety of resources,
and after guzzling down innumerable
cups of hot chocolate-
hey, I'm still a kid, no coffee for me-
I realized part of the problem
was that we actually don't know
a lot about the waste that pollutes
our oceans,
and so I started zeroing down
on the following things
I really want ERVIS to do:
the first, to clean the current waste
floating in the ocean,
second, to analyze the data
from the waste which we collect,
and the third, stopped at source,
which is getting disposed by the ships.
So here's how it works.
The ship is essentially a large boat
with various compartments
and saucers surrounding it.
The working of waste collection
is based on some basic physics concepts,
like saucers which rotate
to capture waste,
a multi-stage cleaner
which is a size-based separation,
and a compactor to compact the trash.
The saucers float on the surface
gravitate to create a whirlpool
to pull the waste towards its center.
These saucers will have a central outlet
which will swallow the waste
and is connected through a tube
to various chambers in the ship.
Imagine a gigantic vacuum cleaner
with many cleaning tubes
attached to many dust bags.
Once the waste enters the tube,
we'll have various stages,
which will then segregate it.
First, we have an infrared sensor,
which alerts ERVIS for marine life.
The waste then goes to various chambers
for processing.
The first chamber is the oil chamber,
which collects waste oil.
The second, third, fourth,
and fifth chambers
are for large, medium, small
and micro-waste respectively.
Once the waste enters those chambers,
we analyze, segregate,
and compact it,
and pump the filtered water
back into the oceans.
Beyond ERVIS, I see myself tackling
other ocean problems,
like the waste which lies
at the bottom of the sea,
and the waste which lies on beaches.
I would like to do more research on
how I can help effectively dispose
of the waste -
maybe process it on the ship itself-
or creating different storage stations
at the oceans for holding the waste.
Collector ships can bring the waste there
and transport ships
can take them back to land.
Someone asked me how confident
I was about the success of ERVIS.
As Chris Anderson wonderfully put it,
this idea exists and will always
remain a part of me,
and nobody can take that away.
Before I end, I want this to be
a new beginning of hope
that one day I will see
my creation in action,
going there,
cleaning the oceans,
and restoring the natural habitat
of our marine world.
Thank you.